one of the
keys to apple is apple's an incredibly
collaborative company
and
so
you know how many committees we have at
apple no
zero
we have no committees no committees we
are a ver we are organized like a
startup
one person is in charge of
iphone os software one person is in
charge of mac hardware one person is in
charge of iphone hardware engineering
another person is in charge of worldwide
marketing another person is in charge of
operations
it's we're organized like a startup
we're the biggest startup on the planet
and
we all meet
for three hours once a week and we talk
about everything we're doing the whole
business
and there's tremendous teamwork at the
top of the company which filters down to
tremendous teamwork throughout the
company and teamwork is dependent on
trusting the other folks to come through
with their part without watching them
all the time but trusting that they're
going to come through with their parts
and
that's what we do really well and we're
great at figuring out how to divide
things up into these great teams that we
have
and all work on the same thing
touch bases frequently
and bring it all together into a product
we do that really well
and so what i do all day
is meet with teams of people
and
work on ideas and solve problems to make
new products to make new marketing
programs whatever it is and are people
willing to tell you you're wrong
yeah i mean other than
snarky journalists i mean people are
working yeah no we have wonderful
arguments
and do you win them all or oh no i wish
i did
oh so you can't
if you want to hire great people and
have them stay working for you you have
to let them
make a lot of decisions and you have to
you have to be run by ideas
not hierarchy the best ideas have to win
so otherwise good people don't stay but
you must be more than a facilitator who
runs meetings you obviously contribute
your own ideas i contribute ideas sure
well why would i be there if i didn't
if you want to see the top 10 rules
video i did on steve jobs check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there and your
your life is just to live your life
inside the world try not to bash into
the walls too much uh try to have a nice
family life have fun
save a little money